c'est demain que la Commission d'expert
doit décider si oui ou non olivier est
en état de quitter l'unité pour malade
difficile
ça c'est de la framboise ouais voilà
c'est par gourmandise c'est un laxatif
qui est bon quoi donc voilà donc du coup
avant le repas voilà tu vois pour lui
c'est une douceur mais bon
les traitements sont lourds donner 4
fois par jour il calme assomme aussi
d'où les difficultés d'élocution des
patients
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauver secourir protéger finalement je
suis journaliste pour vous lui il est
malade c'est sûr mais lui il dit qu'il
est pas malade
et j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ses femmes ordinaires
qui exercent des métiers hors du commun
et aucune possibilité de pendaison ou
que ce soit sous horizontal aujourd'hui
me voici à l'hôpital psychiatrique de
Bron tout près de Lyon dans une UMD une
unité pour malade difficile presque une
prison mais un hôpital qui accueille 40
malades parmi les plus violents
ils sont souvent psychotiques et souvent
schizophrène mais aussi autiste la
plupart ont tués ils sont placés ici
sous contrainte par le préfet parce
qu'ils sont dangereux
[Musique]
ah de pas de lion je crois qu'on est
l'un des plus vieux hôpitaux
psychiatriques de France le Vinatier et
au fond du parc en fait ça commence à
ressembler à une prison le bâtiment
quand on voit de l'extérieur tout est
super calme serein il y a des petits
bâtiments partout et là tout d'un coup
il y a des il y a des murs en béton et
du grillage
j'ai rendez-vous dans cette UMD ouverte
depuis deux ans seulement c'est l'une
des plus récentes il y en a 10 en France
[Musique]
unité pour mal difficile
j'aurais pensé qu'il cachait un peu mais
on assume
jour je suis accueilli par le Docteur
Renaud psychiatre patron de l'unité
enchanté bienvenue merci voilà
distribue notre appareil réglementaire
effectivement pour circuler chez nous en
toute sécurité qui est des alarmes
individuelles portatives comme tous ceux
qui entre ici je dois toujours porter ce
bip sur moi pour donner l'alerte en cas
d'agression vous le tenir à la verticale
c'est la seule particularité un peu
contraignante ce dispositif ça c'est
pour un bip à l'horizontal ça veut dire
qu'on est par terre et donc en danger il
se déclenche automatiquement entrer dans
le dans le site de l'UMD ça ressemble un
peu une prison ça ressemble en tout cas
un lieu qui est fermé et qui est
sécurisé on est bien d'accord que fermer
et sécurisé ça ça ressemble ça peut
aussi avoir des points communs avec avec
l'hiver carcéral la différence c'est
qu'ici on soigne mais dans un lieu
beaucoup plus sécurisé qu'un hôpital
psychiatrique traditionnel
un mur d'enceinte de 7 mètres de haut
des détecteurs de mouvements
des caméras de surveillance aucune
évasion possible
voilà donc là on a nos quatre scènes
d'isolement
ici c'est l'UMD dans l'UMD pour les
malades en pleine crise ce qui arrive
ici ont commis des actes très graves ils
ont tué leurs enfants des capitaines
leur père ou tuer leurs voisins de
cellules en prison
tu vois c'est du sens
[Musique]
et la télé est hors de portée rien ne
doit pouvoir servir d'armes évidemment
que ce soit sous horizontal
de baisser ce genre de réseau
ça s'est déjà vu
chaque chambre d'isolement dispose d'une
cour individuelle grillagée ça fait
froid dans le dos moi qui m'intéresse
aux univers hors normes je suis à fond
dedans
dans la cour je vais rencontrer les
patients et notamment Olivier la
trentaine il a tué son hôpital d'origine
ne sait plus le gérer il est ici depuis
20 mois
[Musique]
et il vient d'apprendre qu'une
commission va bientôt se pencher sur son
cas et peut-être le renvoyer dans son
hôpital sa l'angoisse et sa tombe sur
Slimane l'infirmier
la Commission va se faire ce mois-ci ce
mois-ci exactement
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas de date mais ça va se faire
deux jours c'est ça que je peux vous
dire
vous avez besoin d'avoir des certitudes
vous avez vu vous avez vu comment les
mon lit il est fait vous avez vu comment
on nous a fait avec son ranger ça c'est
vrai je suis comme ça moi j'ai de la
rigueur la rigueur et je programme les
choses j'aime bien programmer les choses
et j'adore
si par exemple ça se passe pas comme
c'est programmé exactement c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave
olivier est un obsessionnel les réponses
de Slimane ne le satisfont pas alors il
va voir Corinne une autre infirmière
alors il t'a dit qu'il y avait pas de
date
[Musique]
c'est exactement ça vous allez sortir
fin novembre si tout se passe bien fin
novembre ou début décembre Slimane est
patient c'est la grande spécialité
d'Olivier harceler le personnel toute la
journée avec la même question c'est pour
ça qu'il est ici il a épuisé son service
psychiatrique d'origine jusqu'à menacer
et violenter le personnel il cherche à
aller au bout du bout jusqu'à avoir la
faille quand même du soignant il y en a
qui ont sont pro là dedans certains
patients qui nous poussent dans nos
retranchements et ça vous ça va nous
faire mal
ils ont pas d'autres moyens d'exprimer
leurs angoisses et leurs tensions ils
nous la balance nous on reçoit ça et on
doit en faire quelque chose
qu'est-ce qui se passe
d'accord bon vous voulez qu'on baisse
les volets un petit peu dans la journée
les patients se reposent en général dans
leur chambre la porte toujours fermée à
clé
ici les infirmiers travaillent au
minimum deux par deux pour la sécurité
mais pas seulement quand on est deux on
est deux à partager ce qu'on va recevoir
du patients c'est moins lourd du coup
on n'est pas seul à porter les choses ce
qui est durent dans ce travail qui
serait dur si on travaille tout seul
de l'unité
mais ça peut se retourner contre nous
des fois
[Musique]
Mathilde est atteinte d'une psychose
infantile elle peut être très violente
même si là maintenant j'ai un peu de mal
à l'imaginer
[Musique]
[Rires]
on peut partager des choses mais il faut
toujours apprendre à garder les bonnes
distances oui mais même quand on rigole
on rigole avec les bonnes distances
dans une MD ça va bien et puis tout d'un
coup ça va mal l'équipe est attentive au
signe avant-coureur et ça peut partir
rien
[Musique]
est-ce que vous faites par terre
qu'est-ce que vous faites par terre
Armel fait un caprice elle veut attirer
l'attention elle a 27 ans et souffrait
aussi d'une psychose infantile
maltraitée dans sa famille et la
pratiquement toujours vécue en hôpital
psychiatrique violente elle est arrivée
à l'UMD de Bron il y a un an et pourrait
partir bientôt on va demander à la
Commission
en décembre votre retour dans votre
région on décembre
et vous n'avez pas envie
d'être déjà allé c'est pas une vie ici
c'est pas pour rester toute seule
[Musique]
aller à Saint-Girons
il est 11h04
et ben vous allez aller fumer vous
perdez pas le nord quand même je crois
que vraiment le changement pour elle ça
va être compliqué elle a loué ici en un
an des liens très forts et puis surtout
elle a un cadre qui est très stricte et
qui finalement le convient elle a vécu
que là-dedans depuis toujours que dans
l'abandon et je te prends et je te
rejette et je te prends et je te rejette
donc là on s'occupe d'elle et quelque
part pour elle c'est une forme de rejet
aussi salut MD les horaires sont
strictes le rythme très cadré le
personnel en nombre ça permet aux
malades très perturbé de se poser
parfois de trouver un équilibre
comme Armel mais il y a d'autres malades
qui ne comprennent pas ce qu'ils font
ici pour faire connaissance rien ne vaut
la pose cigarette
[Musique]
quoi dites-moi c'est quoi que j'ai comme
pathologie j'avais pas le dire
psychorigide moi c'est pas une
psychologue psychorigide c'est pas une
pathologie c'est le personnalité vous
savez ce qu'ils disent les médecins
enfin d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est
que pour commencer à soigner il faut
commencer à admettre qu'on est malade
exactement voilà c'est pas logique vous
souffrez pas vous
je souffre d'être ici parce que c'est
dur de vivre ici mais je souffre pas de
ma maladie je suis pas souffrant malade
c'est quelqu'un qui souffre moi je me
sens je souffre pas je souffre des
enfermé mais est-ce que les gens
souffrent de vous
alors je les ai
il paraît que je les inquiète mais vous
l'avez fait du mal
oui
ça fait 12 ans que je suis en train de
quel sens la vie
c'est très difficile moi je suis bien
dans ma tête je suis bien dans mon corps
mais je suis enfermé je peux pas vivre
ma vie comme je veux c'est un côté
perpète
[Musique]
comme ça vous êtes tous à la prison
du rester dans un hôpital ici avec des
malades parce que discutaient avec des
maths ça va un moment pour discuter bien
tous les quatre
des fois je t'aime je veux dire tes
conneries
c'est-à-dire pour vous lui il est malade
c'est sûr mais lui il dit qu'il est pas
malade
vous le trouvez oui
tu peux le dire oui c'est pas le cas
psychorigide etc
[Rires]
il y a de l'humour quand même il faut
allez
criminel violent la plupart viennent de
prison ou d'hôpitaux psychiatrique où
ils étaient devenus ingérables il reste
à lui MD en moyenne un an avant de
repartir en hôpital classique on ne sort
jamais d'ici pour retourner directement
à la vie normale
Corinne a une longue expérience en
psychiatrie elle sait gérer la nervosité
des patients comme Olivier qui en plus
du reste est aussi toxicomane
ici plus d'Europe plus d'alcool alors il
a tendance à demander en permanence un
rap de médicaments on appelle ça un si
besoin ça ne doit jamais devenir
systématique
ment de ce soir comme hier
on attend un peu là
on attend un peu
je te le donne
15 minutes autant dire une éternité pour
Olivier
Hugo j'ai
dit non j'ai déjà dit non
Corinne
la main dans le sac
je tenais je te connais
il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui Olivier de
quoi être stressé avec son passage en
commission il mise gros s'il gagne la
partie il pourra retourner dans un
hôpital classique
d'ailleurs l'équipe de son hôpital
psychiatrique d'origine a fait le
déplacement ils n'en ont pas forcément
un bon souvenir il était agressif et
violent avec eux c'est pour ça qu'ils
l'ont envoyé à l'UMD et ils veulent
vérifier qu'il va mieux et peut revenir
dans leur service le docteur Bagdad le
psychiatre d'Olivier a l'UMD va devoir
les convaincre
un mois qui est c'est vrai de tout
toxique il peut pas avoir du chiffre à
l'intérieur
je le sens
voilà
il veut vraiment il le dit pas d'alcool
pas de cannabis si au niveau des
addictions est-ce qu'on porte la façon
dont on le connaissait ça tiendra pas
trois jours quoi non mais c'est ça quand
même
ce sont démunis quoi effectivement par
rapport à la
suite
sincèrement enfin moi au jour
d'aujourd'hui je sais pas voilà enfin je
peux pas me projeter parce que je ne
sais pas du tout comment il va être je
pense qu'effectivement les premiers
jours voilà ça risque de bien se passer
après voilà c'est la suite avec aussi la
stimulation on n'a pas effectivement le
même cas donc c'est donc voilà pour
l'instant je peux rien en dire au niveau
ça n'est pas gagné l'équipe a des doutes
mais elle veut bien voir Olivier pour
juger sur pied lui va devoir les séduire
il a vu qu'on avait vu
et Olivier a tout compris pour gagner la
sympathie des soignants il va faire son
autocritique
j'étais associable marginal je mets du
SHIELD
je faisais
la loi j'étais c'est
un souci
je suis allé je suis allé souvent
et au final j'ai magnifique en fait je
dis je vais toucher le fond pour plus
tard
à quelque chose
[Musique]
j'entends en tout cas voilà votre
démarche et votre votre désir mais c'est
les sollicitations voilà
[Rires]
il a pris du poids
on compte sur vous en tout cas monsieur
à tout de suite
il reste comme ça
il a plus confiance en nous et nous on
arrive à plus lui donner aussi confiance
quoi
qu'il a pris conscience que
c'était pas bon avec sa maladie et tout
il disait pas des trucs comme ça
[Musique]
l'équipe a été touchée Olivia marqué des
points pour revenir bientôt dans son
service d'origine
je comprends là que l'UMP joue souvent
le rôle de soupape quand un service tout
entier et sur les dents à cause d'un
patient violent il y a l'UMD qui permet
aux équipes souvent déborder des
hôpitaux psychiatriques de travailler
plus sereinement et donc mieux
c'est le plus grand Corinne et Hugo
travaille ici depuis l'ouverture il y a
deux ans et on dirait que ça leur plaît
vas-y viens à côté de Hugo
vous êtes heureux
[Rires]
même s'il est désespérant parfois c'est
moi j'adore mon boulot quoi
[Musique]
puis moi en tout cas ça me permet de
grandir voilà d'apprendre des choses
prendre du recul sur énormément de
choses voilà je pense que ça me fait du
bien aussi donc non non c'est je suis
hyper content au travail vraiment je
prends du plaisir
[Musique]
à la tombée de la nuit au beau milieu
d'une partie de cartes la gaieté de
Mathilde s'est évaporé
calme-toi
[Musique]
attends 2 secondes
Corinne prévient tout de suite ses
collègues que Mathilde montant pression
oui
exploser dans les doigts à mon avis
avant ce soir
calme-toi on est au courant
je te dis de te calmer là
elle est en train de se
Corinne passe le relais à Hugo qui va
tenter le dialogue
elle va clasher là
mais Mathilde ne se calme pas
contente ça va pas bien
[Musique]
de ta mère la [__]
tu veux un goût
Mathilde se débat elle refuse de
regagner sa chambre
[Musique]
ils attendent du renfort pour la porter
en toute sécurité sans qu'elle ne se
blesse ou blesse quelqu'un d'autre
il déboule des infirmiers des aides
soignants de partout dans la chambre ils
sont au moins 8 pour lui poser les
sangles de contention qui vont
l'attacher au lit
Mathilde se défend comme une furie et
leur crash dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Seine est assez pénible pour
quelqu'un de non averti
à demain
c'est aussi difficile pour l'équipe
soignante qui se prend de plein fouet la
violence des patients
c'est vraiment le passage à l'acte ça
sort et puis en plus
parce que la chambre peut être contente
elle se fait du mal elle se mord elle se
met les doigts dans les yeux elle tire
sur sa langue elle s'étrangle enfin
c'est pas possible quoi tu es sûr c'est
un
autre
rétrécissement de la liberté déjà ici à
l'UMD on peut considérer que ça comme
une grande chambre d'isolement
les chambres c'est voilà et la
contention c'est pour le coup le bout du
bout le bout du bout voilà surtout en
chambre d'isolement voilà aussi après
ceci dit pour les patients ça les
rassemble ça les pousse à leur fait du
bien ça leur permet aussi de pas se
mettre en danger de pas nous mettre en
danger donc c'est quelque chose qui
franchement nécessaire
la moitié de nos patients c'est des
patients qui sont ni hyper hyper
dangereux pour être tout le temps
enfermé mais qui tiennent pas en service
d'entrée c'est des patients comme tu
sais on a beaucoup cette population là
c'est un peu les
relayés de la psychiatrie qui sont pas
assez bien pour être en service d'entrée
mais qui n'ont pas forcément de profil
lui-même des parce qu'on va pas en faire
des miracles et on les changera pas donc
peut-être une échelon en fait c'est à
l'UMD il a un caractère très sécuritaire
quand même
et il manque un échelon qui serait
effectivement ces gens que les services
c'est ça un service très contenant avec
des soignants bien disponibles tout en
faisant des accompagnements des choses
mais ça ne nécessite pas toutes ces
caméras ces murs on s'est grillage c'est
pas enfin moi en tout cas
personnellement je vois pas le profil
d'une patiente UMD non pas pour elle
donc là en fait il va me dire rempli un
rôle parce que personne ne remplit quoi
parce que personne peut le remplir
c'est vrai
qui je suis moi
je pique
elle est super calme
le chichon le chichon le cannabis qui
pourrait trouver
le lendemain matin le service est calme
au petit déjeuner des infirmiers
l'ambiance est détendue
[Musique]
[Rires]
fait même le pitre
[Musique]
j'en suis presque sûre
on peut pas être sûr du tout
quand elle n'est pas d'humeur à rapper
Armelle cogne avec la force d'un
rugbyman regarde du plaquage rugby et
Stéphane le prof de sport
c'est parti pour le grand défouloir
ça y est on a réussi
et on souffle un peu non c'est
abandonnes ou pas
le prof est bientôt plus essoufflé que
son élève dont l'énergie est débordante
[Musique]
un petit peu allez c'est bien
voilà
ah mais c'était la croûte que tu avais
la dernière fois ça c'est quoi ça c'est
quand tu tapes
ouais c'est quand tu tapes dans les dans
les dans les armoires et dans les portes
on a une spécialiste des coups de pied
dans les portes et des coups de poing
dans les murs
il n'y a pas que les murs de l'U MD qui
retiennent les patients et ici c'est un
luxe comparé à un hôpital classique il y
a un infirmier ou un aide-soignant pour
un malade
l'heure des traitements
et devinez qui est le premier de la file
Olivier notre monsieur médicament
le si besoin ça va pas que le traitement
normal c'est déjà c'est le traitement
indiqué le si besoin c'est plus tard si
tu peux pas gérer ce qu'il a dit le
médecin
quand je suis enfermé
et j'ai besoin de
palier à tout ça
c'est demain que la Commission d'expert
doit décider si oui ou non olivier est
en état de quitter l'unité pour maladie
difficile
ça c'est de la framboise ouais voilà
c'est par gourmandise un laxatif qui est
bon quoi donc voilà donc du coup
tout sera avant le repas voilà tu vois
pour lui c'est une douceur mais bon
les traitements sont lourds donner
quatre fois par jour il calme assomme
aussi d'où les difficultés d'élocution
des patients
des fois oui des fois non parce que des
fois tu m'énerves
qu'est-ce que je fais quand je fais
énervé
je prends un
je prends quoi quand je suis énervé
elle sait tout
quand elle m'a énervée une journée et
que je suis fatiguée quand je rentre je
prends un bain
alors des fois
quand elle est saute
[Musique]
c'est entre nous ok d'accord je le dis
pas
allez maintenant tu vas là-bas
et puis soudain c'est l'alerte générale
un incident à l'autre bout du bâtiment
tout le monde a cours pour prêter main
forte les bips tentatives indiquent là
où ça se passe
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
à l'acte
[Musique]
et sans aucune raison ce malade en a
frappé un autre au visage
l'agresseur est tout de suite
immobilisée et porté dans sa chambre on
vous attache au lit il faut que vous
soyez en sécurité
pour vous protéger vous-même et puis
qu'on se protège nous aussi d'accord
après vous décidez de m'expliquer un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que vous souffrez là est-ce que
vous avez besoin d'un calmant
je vais vous faire un petit traitement
quand même hein
qui puisse s'apaiser au moins parce que
ce que je sais aussi c'est que quand ça
part comme ça c'est que dans la tête
c'est très compliqué
le malade semble complètement perdu
comme dépassé par sa propre violence
qui je suis moi
[Musique]
je savais plus
l'injection pour que vous puissiez être
apaisé
parce que quand vous êtes trop mal comme
ça il faut pouvoir vous soulager
que tout seul vous y arrivez pas
j'y vais je pique
respirez j'enlève l'aiguille
[Musique]
on met le pansement et c'est terminé un
peu vous luttez pas contre ça vous
laissez un petit peu aller vous vous
reposez d'accord
[Musique]
il a mis un coup de poing un autre
patient et ça a commencé et puis là il
est on a du mal à le raccrocher quoi
alors refaire venir à nous donc là
l'idée c'est déjà de sécuriser les
choses qui s'appelle et puis après on va
essayer de renouer un petit peu le il se
souviendra
la violence a surgit sans crier gare
l'équipe assure réagir vite avec calme
et humanité alors que tous se sont déjà
fait frapper insulter cracher dessus
pourquoi revenir pourquoi être là
pourquoi soigner
vous exercez malgré tout un métier qui
est risqué puisque vous êtes contact de
personnalité
psychiquement dangereuse qui peuvent à
n'importe quel moment
commettre y compris des meurtres comment
est-ce que vous gérez ça vous pouvez
prendre un coup de poing
à chaque minute de votre activité en
zone commune en tout cas ou même dans
les chambres ce qui nous protège quand
même en bout de chaîne finalement c'est
d'avoir à l'esprit que ce que le patient
nous exprime nous nous est pas adressé
directement c'est quand même un message
qui s'adresse à lui-même en fait parce
que bon le patient lui il en souffrance
et l'expression de sa souffrance se
manifeste en psy par l'agressivité il a
pas tellement d'autres moyens lui il a
pas la capacité d'élaborer de s'exprimer
avec des mots de ressentir ses émotions
de se dire bah tiens là ce qui m'a dit
ça m'a touché et puis d'échanger avec
moi ça il peut pas donc ça va sortir un
moment donné autrement
l'art de notre boulot c'est d'avoir une
vigilance et de savoir repérer les
signes avant-coureur de violence de
savoir décoder un peu les attitudes
[Musique]
il paraît qu'on ne vient pas travailler
en psychiatrie par hasard
[Musique]
en fait elle
elle est super calme
et trop de l'avoir comme ça
[Musique]
19h c'est l'heure du repas les patients
mangent par petits groupes toute la
vaisselle est en plastique c'est bon
la maternelle
on leur donne du jambon blanc de la
purée
mon corps je suis autonome peut avoir un
couteau chez m'en servir c'est que c'est
pas pour tuer des gens maintenant
je suis pas un malade comme un peu
partout
je vais pas me laisser faire voilà je
suis capable de tuer c'est vrai mais pas
comme un malade de ma bandit autour de
cette table des hommes qui pratiquement
tous tués et pourtant on peut parler
avec eux normalement
certains sont même attachants
ils sont drôles c'est fou dangereux qui
s'yrote leur tisane du soir
[Musique]
allez savoir s'ils ne sont pas en train
à force d'attention et de soins de se
reconnecter un peu à la communauté des
hommes
[Musique]
le lendemain c'est le grand jour pour
Olivier
il y a pas besoin de le réveiller
comment ça va il est 8h et il a tendance
sa chambre droit comme un i déjà douché
le lit au carré c'est aujourd'hui que
les experts doivent statuer sur son
éventuelle sortie de cette unité
quasi-carcérale pour retourner à
l'hôpital psy normal
tu as bien dormi
[Musique]
au même moment
son psychiatre s'apprête à passer sur le
grill dans cette salle la fameuse
commission cinq psychiatres tous
extérieurs à l'établissement pour
garantir l'impartialité de ce jury dont
la responsabilité est lourde
je pense qu'il est prêt pour réintégrer
une unité de psychiatrie classique voilà
je pense
de soi ambulatoire tu écris qui est
monsieur a présenté ses excuses ces
remords et Julie aussi
cet élément a été bien perçu par
l'équipe préférantes qui s'inquiète des
bonnes conditions de retour du patient
dans leur unité ils ont la trouille
c'est un patient qui est vachement qui
perturbe vachement le soin et ça nous un
petit peu de les rassurer aussi et par
cette synthèse ils ont vu un petit peu
le patient et du coup j'étais un petit
peu
surpris étonné de cette amélioration
et j'y crois oui
pendant que le docteur Bagdad se fait
cuisiner et joue son va tout pour son
patient la pression monte pour Olivier
c'est normal c'est un bon spray
il faut pas que ça vous envahisse trop
mais c'est bien d'avoir du stress
ça va bien se passer et dans sa
stratégie de séduction un petit
rafraîchissement s'impose
du matin
avant père petite demande
le chichon le chichon le cannabis qui
pourrait trouver dans une autre unité
comme on vois-tu ça le cannabis autre
produit donc en tout cas il est c'est
vrai ça depuis au moins 20 mois c'est
vrai qu'on a pas les garanties à 100%,
on peut pas derrière lui tout le temps
pour la tentation de reprendre les
toxiques mais voilà il faut qu'il
maintenant qui passe
à l'extérieur pour voir
cette évolution
positive si elle se maintient ou pas
l'heure du face-à-face décisif son
enfance merci
c'est normal
le plus adapté sur le moment en fait
comme bon vous semble
allez on compte sur vous on est avec
vous Olivier va affronter les experts
seul ils ont lu son dossier il ne le
connaissent pas et ont suffisamment
d'expérience pour ne pas se faire
embrouiller la tête le docteur Bagdad
reste à la porte pour ne pas influencer
le diagnostic final bonjour monsieur
vous savez dans quelles conditions nous
recevons
[Musique]
j'ai pu assister de façon exceptionnelle
à une partie de cet entretien
vous êtes depuis 18 mois dans cette UMD
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de ce
qui s'est passé pour vous pendant ces 18
mois par rapport à
ce que j'ai fait annoncer j'ai compris
que c'est c'est pas grave qu'il fallait
pas faire ça du tout c'était pas
comportement
comme le site social on pouvait pas
vivre en société comme ça il fallait
apprendre à respecter les gens
et voilà quoi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans l'UMD pour que vous arriviez à
cette position de me dire critique
qu'est-ce qui vous ont fait ici
moi sont bien occupés
j'étais attaché au lit quelques fois
parce que ça allait pas c'est un mal
pour un bien il y a le sport ça m'a fait
ça m'a redonné
[Musique]
la suite se passe sans moi je vais
attendre dehors avec les psychiatres de
l'UMD au bout d'une demi-heure Olivier
ressort complètement KO alors
si on parle de la prison
ils m'ont
c'est pas la réalité
vous avez effacé vous avez défendu votre
position
dans la relation après en effet ce qui
vous ont dit c'est des faits réels mais
je pense que vous pouvez déjà dire
du soin que vous prenez conscience de
tout ça ça vous aidera aussi à mémoriser
ce temps à l'extérieur
[Musique]
vous avez aussi comme obligation de
défendre votre position vous allez pas
vous laisser écraser par le soin vous le
consommez et vous devez aussi défendre
vos projets d'hommes et c'est les deux
qu'il faut tenir en même temps à la fois
se soigner au titre de cette position
défendre des possibilités de son avenir
et de ce qu'on veut faire de soi plus
tard
après 20 minutes de délibération la
commission rend sa décision
[Musique]
bon donc on va vous faire part de nos
conclusions
et puis de
des points qu'on voudrait bien souligner
pour vous
donc nous sommes favorables votre tour
dans une unité de psychiatrie générale
au vu de votre état actuel et de
l'ensemble de votre amélioration
clinique pendant votre séjour à l'UMD
mais faut qu'on entoure cette avis de
recommandations vous allez avoir besoin
de soins hospitaliers complets pendant
longtemps et de soins intensifs
donc la priorité n'est pas la question
de la réinsertion elle est totalement la
priorité elle est totalement ou soit
super content que vous soyez content
c'est une chose
mais je vous redis monsieur
votre situation
quand vous êtes exposé aux produits ou à
certains de vos comportements vous rend
particulièrement dangereux
mille fois
l'important c'est que vous fassiez un
travail de soins dans la durée et que ce
soit pris très au sérieux c'est à dire
que l'équipe qui sera avec vous sera
nous le recommandons effectivement très
vigilante
et proche
et attentive
bonne continuation et surtout
soignez-vous et écoutez bien les
recommandations qu'on vient de vous
faire elles sont importantes
une poignée de main un premier pas vers
la sortie
j'espère que ça tiendra dehors peut-être
on va pas le laisser partir
un projet qui va bien au bout
l'aboutissement un peu de notre de notre
travail avec vous un an et demi
olivier est heureux bien qu'encore sonné
par la nouvelle dans quelques semaines
il quittera l'UMD pour son service de
psychiatrie d'origine toujours
hospitalisé sous contrainte
car l'UMD ne guérit pas elle est en SAS
une soupape les patients en sortent
souvent apaisés mais toujours malade
certains arrivent parfois au bout de
plusieurs années à retrouver une vie
presque normale d'autres ne sortent
jamais du circuit des EMD qui deviennent
alors une sorte de voie de garage pour
les grands malades de notre société
mon séjour à Lyon est terminé demain
ailleurs j'ai rendez-vous avec d'autres
hommes d'autres femmes au VIPER